say why are we still waiting on these
projects why is this happening why is
this happening come on get something
going and apparently according to the
rumor Mike Hopkins has insisted that
Amazon MGM pictures announce something
coming out of the MGM back catalog now
he wants something big announced
immediately now that could be Bond it
could be Stargate it could be something
else but Mike Hopkins has basically now
said I've had enough of this to be
honest like we have we've been waiting
18 months for a big MGM announcement and
we've had nothing get on with it I don't
care if it's RoboCop Stargate Bond get
me something now to me that is music to
my ears because I've been as frustrated
as many of you we keep hearing about
these false starts we keep hearing about
rumors regarding starget and bond and
other things but nothing